hey Vsauce Michael here let's take a
moment to recognize the heroes who count
Canadian Mike Smith holds the world
record for the largest number counted
two in one breath a hundred and twenty
five but the world record for the
largest number ever counted two belongs
to Jeremy Harper from Birmingham Alabama
in order to set the record Harper never
left his apartment he got regular sleep
but from the moment he woke up in the
morning until the moment he went to bed
at night Harper did nothing but count he
streamed the entire process over the
Internet and raised money for charity
while doing it but after three months of
counting all day every day he finally
reached the world record 1 million now a
million might not sound like a lot but
think of it this way
one thousand seconds is about 17 minutes
but a million seconds is more than
eleven days and a billion seconds well
that's more than 31 years there's no
full video online of Harper counting all
the way to a million but you can watch
John Hart Chuck count all the way to
100,000 if you have 74 hours to spare
John also has some other channels one
involves more than 300 videos of himself
eating carrots another more than 3,000
videos of himself drinking water
many of John's videos literally have no
views they are as lonely as a video on
YouTube can get a great way to find such
videos is a website made by Yann Vander
cruson this website autoplays videos on
YouTube that no one has yet watched John
and Jeremy as well as Mike the one
breath counter counted like this 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 and so on but that's not the only
way to count and it doesn't seem to be
the one we're born with additive
counting is the one we're all familiar
with where each next step is just
added to the last but what if we
multiplied by a number instead well that
kind of counting is logarithmic from
Erath most meaning number and logos
meaning ratio proportion on this scale
similar distances are similar
proportions one is a third of three and
three is a third of nine four is a third
of twelve and so on our brains perceive
the world around us on a logarithmic
scale it's believed that almost all of
our senses are multiplicative not
additive for example how loud we
perceive a sound to be to boomboxes
playing at the same volume don't sound
twice as loud as one in order to make a
sound that is perceived as being about
twice as loud as one boombox
you actually need ten times as many so
ten and to double that loudness you
would need a hundred and to double that
loudness you would need a thousand
having an intuitive sense of logarithmic
scales built into your brain is probably
an advantage when it comes to natural
selection and survival because often
proportion matters more than absolute
value for example is there one lion
hiding over there in the shadows or two
is a very different question then are
there 96 lions about to attack us or
ninety seven sure in both cases I'm just
talking about one extra lion but adding
one lion to one lion doubles the threat
adding one lion
to 96 well that's basically nothing
mother admits thinking and feeling they
explain why life seems to speed up as we
get older it seems like I was a child
forever and then college in my early 20s
just whizzed by and logarithmically that
makes sense because each new year that I
live is a smaller fraction of all the
other years I've already lived when you
turn 2 years old the last year of your
life is half your life but when you turn
81 that last year that you've lived well
that's just a tiny part of the other 80
that you know logarithmic thinking isn't
always helpful especially in scenarios
where proportion doesn't logically
matter but we nonetheless act like it
does one of my favorite examples is the
psychophysics of Christ's paradox this
is something almost all of us do
research has found consistently that
people are willing to put a lot of
effort into saving five dollars off a
$10 purchase but they won't put much
$2,000 purchase it's five dollars saved
either way but our natural obsession
with proportion leads us astray take a
look at these pictures can you tell how
many objects are in each of them you
probably can it's like really easy you
can tell if there are 0 1 2 3 or 4
objects in a photo without even needing
to count how are you doing that is it
some sort of sixth sense no
psychologists call it sabotaging we can
intuitively at a glance determine
whether there are about four or fewer
objects in a photo this has been part of
human culture for a very long time and
it may be the reason so many tally
systems from all over the world all
through history wind up having to do
something different when counting the
number 5 when estimating or comparing
amounts above 4 the brain uses what's
known as an approximate number system
it's a psychological ability we have
that's about 15% accurate if two amounts
are at least 15 percent different we can
tell so for example 100 objects and
fifteen or a thousand and eleven fifty
or twelve hundred if you want to test
the accuracy of your approximate number
system panamath has a pretty good test
we often take linear additive counting
for granted but it's not granted to us
we aren't born with it we are however
born with the ability to subah ties and
use an approximate number system
children younger than the age of three
can tell without counting that this line
of four coins contains fewer coins than
this line of six even if you spread the
four coins out into a line that is
physically bigger longer than this line
of six
however mysteriously around the age of
three and a half children lose this
ability and begin saying that this line
of six coins contains fewer coins than
this long line of just four coins
possibly because around this age the
physical world of objects of physical
sizes is more salient in their minds but
then when they begin to learn linear
counting they reverse back and begin
again correctly saying that this line of
six contains more coins in this line of
four around the age of four the smallest
physical thing science could ever hope
to observe is the Planck length in order
to look at anything smaller you would
need to have so much energy concentrated
in such a small area a black hole would
form and you would lose whatever you
were looking at okay with that in mind
here's a question what number is halfway
in between one and nine five seems like
the obvious answer there are four
numbers on either side of five it's
halfway between right well if you ask
this question of a young child or a
member of a culture that doesn't teach a
linear additive number line their answer
will be three you see they are
exhibiting the human minds natural
logarithmic tendency because three in
that sense makes sense three is three
times larger than one and nine is three
times larger than three three is in the
middle proportionately
but what if we took that logarithmic
number line and changed the one to be
the smallest thing we can observe the
plunk link and the nine to be the
largest thing we can observe the
observable universe what would go in the
middle well as it turns out we would the
number of plunk lengths you could
stretch across a brain cell is equal to
the number of your brain cells it would
take to stretch all the way across the
observable universe so welcome to the
middle and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
hello again
the YouTube channel filled date recently
gave me an opportunity to explore
Whittier Alaska one of the strangest
places
humans call home to see why and to see
me investigate talk to the locals click
the link in this video's description or
on the annotation here on this video it
was really fun so give it a little
lookie look